nina simone en pleine émission télé le
saxophoniste ornette coleman aux
violents ou encore qui correa en grande
discussion son café à la main en tout
ces quinze clichés donne un aperçu du
talent de christian roze une des grandes
signatures de la photographie du jazz et
des musiques actuelles
il saisit l'instant hors concert ou
dévoile une facette méconnue des plus
grands jazzmen
il ya beaucoup de photos d'eux christian
heureuse dans des disons or spectacle
parce que finalement c'est ça qui est
intéressant c'est ce rapport humain
qu'il a avec les gens des photos de
musiciens avoir est presque à écouter
qui s'expose pour la 25e édition du
festival jazz de mars
en eure et loir un festival qui une
nouvelle fois reçoit des grands noms
comme laurent de wild ou chris potter
des artistes qui apprécient l'intimité
des salles d'aurélien
on a eu une très grande saxophoniste
géraldine laurent
c'est notre plus grand de 5 sauf au nice
française qui est venue dimanche à
neyron in iron 1 sans mentir c'est une
toute petite ville et la salle est très
mignonne mais elle ne fait que 100
places parce que dans le jazz depuis
toujours il y à cette forme de
simplicité qui fait qu'on va jouer dans
des petites caves dans des petits lieux
en tout ce sont 18 du département qui
accueilleront 23 concerts événements des
moments dont on gardera peut-être une
impression de grâce comme sur cette
photo le cassandre house